il est arrivé en avance alors qu'il
était prévu aujourd'hui pour 15h le
premier trailer de GTA 6 tant attendu
est sorti dans la nuit de lundi à mardi
on va en parler pourquoi est-ce qu'il
est sorti en avance et surtout qu'est-ce
qu'on y apprend dans ce trailer on va le
le découvrir le décrypter et pour cela
je suis avec clloétier merci clloé
d'être avec nous bonjour Merci
aujourd'hui redctrist en chef adjoint
média et tech au Figaro echo on va comme
je disais décrypter vous n'hésitez pas
les inter du Figaro à poser vos
questions question on le découvre
ensemble ce trailer aussi bon déjà cl
généralement qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qu'on
en pense au réveil alors vous avez vu
vous ce ce ce trailer au réveil
qu'est-ce que vous en avez pensé quand
je pense que comme beaucoup de Français
on est on s'est levé ce matin et on a
fait waouh en fait Noël est en avance
parce qu'on l'attendait bah comme vous
disiez pour cet après-midi le trailer et
il est sorti en fait alors pour nous à
minuit ou 1h du matin quelque chose
comme ça en France alors pourquoi et ben
parce qu'il y a une fuite les images en
fait le trailer a été diffusé par un
compte Twitter dans la soirée et donc
Rockstar a décidé bah de voilà de
bazarder ses plans et d'avancer la
diffusion de la bande annonce donc quand
même de quasiment 15h à l'avance he donc
c'est quand même pas rien donc je pense
qu'ils ont passé une très mauvaise
soirée chez enfin une très mauvaise fin
de journée chez Rockstar mais en tout
cas voilà enfin nous voyons les images
de cette de ce jeu qui est attendu par
Internet depuis quasiment 10 ans depuis
la sortie de GTA 5 hein bah ouais
quasiment parce que enfin vous savez
comment sont les les comment sont les
jou le jeu est à peine sorti qu' veulent
la suite donc voilà ça fait 10 ans que
nous avons des rumeurs diverses et
variées autour de GTA VI et ben là ça y
est on sait enfin à quoi ça ressemble
voilà on a vu ses premières images GTA 5
était sortie le 17 septembre
2013 10 ans déjà que ce que c vidéo
était sortie voilà le deuxè vous
n'hésitez pas bien sûr à N poser
question alors on va retourner sur ce
trailer et le regarder petit à
petit vous le voyez sur Youtube euh là
nous sommes sur et là on voit tout de
suite ce plan alors déjà on peut on peut
en parler de l'endroit où passer ce ce
ce GTA euh exit la côte ouest on repart
sur la côte Est ouais et cette fois on
va à Miami enfin à va City comme cela
s'appelle dans le monde de GTA euh donc
ouais donc là nous partons en Floride
donc à nous les bikinis et le soleil et
la plage euh et les crocodiles la annonp
beaucoup
là ça va avec c'est dans le paquet du de
la Floride euh non mais en fait alors ça
va rappeler des souvenirs aux plus vieux
d'entre nous dont je fais partie euh
parce que moi mon premier GTA c'était
GTA Vice City euh qui était sorti 2002
voilà c'est mon premier c'est mon
premierity c'est mon premier GTA c'est
le premier GTA donc donc voilà donc la
cité du vice euh donc on est cont Miami
visiss et cetera donc on est voilà on
est content de retourner donc après
parce que les derniers épisodes c'était
Los Angeles hm hm et avant c'était New
York New yor s Andreas c'était aussi Los
Angeles Ctait Los Angeles aussi donc
Miami l'ont fait une fois et ben hop on
y repart on y retourne avec cette belle
cette belle couleur alors déjà aussi les
graphismes les graphismes qui sont quand
mêmeoui alors je dois dire ça été un peu
la claque de ce matin j'ai fait ah oui
quand même ah oui on est capable de
faire ça au niveau jeux vidéos alors on
a toujours des très très beaux jeux
vidéos mais là on se dit ah oui Rockstar
c'est alors on le sait qui ça fait faire
des très beaux jeux quand Red Dead
redomtion était sorti en8 on s était dit
c'est incroyblement magif h et là on se
redit la même chose aujourd'ui B on se
redit la même chose alors moi j'aimerais
savoir sur quelle machine tourne cette
bandeannonce parce que j'ai du mal à
croire que ça pe être de la Playstation
5 euh à mon avis c'est un trailer PC euh
et donc j'aimerais savoir à quel point
ça ressemblera ou pas à ça en vrai quand
ça sortira donc on verra s'il y aura ce
qu'on appelle le dowrade qui est le mot
Oni de tous les gamers donc c'est-à-dire
quand le drade c'estàd que quand la la
présentation du jeu euh bon bah le
produit final c'est pas tout à fait ça
on a quand même un peu baissé baissé en
qualité donc là nous verrons dis donc
que on vous montre comment ça marche sur
une machine qui coûte 200000 € ou 200000
€ et sur la vôre voilà celle qui coûte
500 B mais sans mais voilà sans plus
donc vous voyez ces images avec le
personnage principal l'un des
personnages principal on s'attendait pas
forcément à en entendre parler déjà mais
en tout cas voilà on a son identité
alors il y avait beaucoup de lic aussi
autour alors là déjà c'est sorti mais il
y a un an il y avait énormément de lit
qu'on savait déjà pas mal de choses qui
n'avaient pas forcément été validé mais
là voilà c'est h nous Jons ouais on va
donc on va jouer une femme ce qui est
quand même une grande première dans
toute la saga GTA euh donc elle sera en
duo avec son petit ami tout façon on le
voit bien dans le dans le trailer donc
on aura certainement choix entre les
deux personnages euh et ouais en fait
l'année dernière il y avait eu un gros
un gros piratage des serveurs de de chez
Rockstar et donc beaucoup de choses
étaient sorties dans la nature et
notamment voilà que un ça se passait à
Miami ça on le savait depuis un an et
deux on savait qu'on allait jouer on
allait jouer une femme une sorte de bon
CDE à la sauce floridienne euh donc donc
voilà donc on va dire pas vraiment de
surprise hein sur là-dessus parce que
malheureusement enfin heureusement
malheureusement ça dépend dans quel camp
vous êtes euh sous ces détails là était
déjà connus et et on reprend aussi la
formule de de narration de GTA V où il y
avait trois personnages à jouer et qui
faisait chacun avancer l'intrigue là on
peut s'attendre peut-être à quelque
chose un peu verra on verra on verra
s'il reprennent le même système alors
pour ceux qui ont joué au 5 et Dieu sait
que vous êtes nombreux euh bon si vous
vous souvenez en fait on pouvait passer
ver V de manière très fluide d'un
personnage à un autre d'un coin à un
autre de Los Angeles il y avait juste un
bouton à toucher et paf on passerit au
personnag enfin on naviguer entre les
trois bon là on va voir pour le moment
ils ont pas vraiment montré le gameplay
tel qu'il sera dans le jeu donc pour
moment on en éch supposition mais a
priori voilà s'il y a deux personnages
jouables on devrait pouvoir jongler
entre les deux gameplay entre les deux
donc on voit lu qui sort a priori de
prison et là voilà on voit les les
premières images mi de Miami on voit ces
images qui sont absolument euh
magnifique alors là aussi alors pour
revenir un peu en arrière déjà ça ça
rappelle forcément ce qu'on voyait à sur
VI City euh ces images du du Strip de la
de la de la plage qui est magnifique en
version euh 800 fois plus grande ah bah
en version beaucoup plus belle que ce
qu'on a connu en 2002 euh mais oui oui
en fait bah ça me fait penser toute
proportion gardée quand on a découvert
le Los Angeles de GTA V c'était la carte
pour l'époque était était immense mais
aussi enfin ce qui est sympa c'est quand
on connaît les vraies villes c'est
toujours chouette de découvrir alors moi
par exemple j'ai découvert Los Angeles
d'abord via GTA avant de le découvrir en
vrai et ça c'est une expérience à vivre
en fait dans ce sens là parce on fait
genre ah ouais quand même euh vous es
déjà la Miami alors bah non jamais donc
je dé faend alors il faudra attendre
2025 à prior enfin on parlera de ça plus
tard aussi non mais c'est là on voit que
en fait le travail de reconstitution est
vraiment bien fait par rapport aux
ambiances sonores notamment les villes
bon elles sont pastichées c'est pas tout
à fait ça c'est pas le plan exact de
circulation évidemment certains
quartiers sont vraiment concentrés par
rapport à la réalité mais en tout cas on
a une voilà ça représente bien l'esprit
de de ces villes et ça c'est vraiment un
très gros travail qu'ils font à chaque
fois forcément d'arriver alors il y a il
y a des villes on le voit mais il y a
aussi de
la les marais les
Baillou le Baillou Florin parce que ça
ne se pas alors que Vice City se passa
énormément justement dans les ville on
le rappelle ce jeu qui est sorti en 2002
là pour le coup on va pouvoir a priori
se balader dans la campagne CAG GTA bien
bah c'est très bien parce qu'on faisait
déjà ça dans le GTA V même si
malheureusement c'était pas très
exploité euh une fois voilà qu'on avait
découvert le personnage de Trevor euh
qui était enfin une une respiration
incroyable pour ceux qui ont fait GTA V
voilà ont passé deune dizaine d'heures
on était vraiment dans Los Angeles à un
moment donné paf on sort et on va dans
un monde totalement différent qui était
bah celui des voilà des personnes
défavorisées qui vivent dans des
caravanes et qui sont euh voilà qui sont
qui éta un petit peu dangereux on va
dire euh donc en fait ça me permettait
de montrer une autre versant du rêve
américain et donc là je pense qu'ils
vont se faire plaisir et aussi nous
montrer que Miami c'est pas que la
flambe et le blingbling euh c'est aussi
en Floride voilà des personnes qui vont
vivre dans des conditions franchement
pas géniales oui ça on va le voir
d'ailleurs un peu plus tard dans ce dans
ce dans cette bandeannonce vous allez le
voir donc voilà le Baillou les plages
magnifiquesis les les horbard on va
pouvoir refaire du bateau non puis moi
je vois les les bateaux moi je vois
surtout les transporteurs les les euh
les cargot cargo les cargot donc drogue
tous les coups souvent souvent souvent
des grandes missions de drogue sur le
sur le doc on va dire exactement donc ça
c'est un grand classique de GTA parce
que ce n'est pas un jeu pour les enfants
euh donc voilà on fait quand même
beaucoup d'activités criminelles dans
GTA donc évidemment ça sent que il y
aura des questions de trafic de drogue
c'est quasiment sûr effectivement on
voyez donc ces images de nuit qui sont
tourné le côté quartier le le côté gang
là on voit quelque chose qui va nous
rappeler aussi des des souvenirs c'est
les low riders ces fameuses voitures
qu'on peut customiser il y en aura a
priori aussi dans GTA ouais oua ouais
bah tout façon je pense qu'on va
retrouver pas mal de enfin de la sauce
classique de de GTA mais ce qui moi
j'attends de voir c'est qu'est-ce qu'ils
vont apporter vraiment de neuf à cette
recette parce que c'est une recette qui
est extrêmement bien éprouvée depuis
maintenant fin 80 fin des années 90 le
fr le premier GTA c'était 97 euh voilà
on connaît la sauce on connaît la
recette elle marche extrêmement bien
mais voilà est-ce que est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'on va apporter de plus
est-ce qu'ils vont réussir à s'adapter
les boîtes de nuit les gangs on le
disait ces plans voilà toujours voilà un
jeu magnifique le Strip de de
Miami vous voyez ces images de boîte de
nuit ça c'est on va faire de l'avion on
va faire de l'avion la pointe ça c'est
la pointe de la de la Floride avec on le
voit aussi c'est c'est bateau cargot
pourrait dire qu'on pourrait peut-être
réussir à à faire du bateau cargot ah
bah peut-être mais je pense que tout est
possible façon dans GTA 5 on pit pouvit
conduire à peu près tout et n'importe
quoi c'est la première fois je CIS qu'on
pouvait aller dans les airs donc là bon
il vont puis bon les bateaux existaient
déjà mais là ils vont pe-être pousser
encore plus parce que le milieu le
milieu de Miami le permet donc oui je
pense qu'ils vont être encore plus
imaginatifs surtout ce qu'on parce que
GTA c'est un immense terrain de jeu en
fait on fait enfin c'est la la promesse
de ce jeu et qui fait qu'il fonctionne
aussi bien c'est qu'on fait à peu près
ce qu'on veut il y a une mission mais
bon on n'est pas obligé de la suivre on
n'est pas obligé bon après bon c'est
quand même mieux de suivre les enfin
pour avancer dans le jeu de faire les
missions mais après à côté de ça c'est
un bacassable donc vous faites ce que
vous voulez vous pouvez aller en boîte
de nuit vous pouvez euh vous pouvez vous
balader dans la rue vous pouvez être un
gentil citoyen si vous le souhaitez vous
pouvez les règles exactement vous pouvez
respecter règ donc vous pouvez faire un
peu ce que vous voulez dans ce jeu donc
là ouais je suis curieuse de voir
jusqu'où ils vont aller et aussi je suis
curieuse parce que les GTA notamment
depuis le 4 c'est des très bonnes
représentations de de nos sociétés euh
et notamment enin sur sur des petits
points par exemple internet dans le GTA
4 pour accéder à Internet fallait dans
des cyber cafés et dans le 5 on avait
directement accès à des simili Facebook
et Twitter sur le téléphone il y a un
grand arc narratif autour de facebook
justement alors pas un vrai Facebook
avec le fondateur de Facebook qui se
fait tuer pendant une mission c'est
c'est enfin c'est aussi ça qui est mis
en avant par GTA mais c'est ça en fait
qu'on aime aussi dans GTA c'est ce côté
un peu cette C ti de notre monde réel
donc là je ouis j'ai aussi hâte de voir
sur quoi est-ce qu'ils vont appuyer
cette fois-ci parce qu'on sait bon ils
appuient toujours sur les dérives du
rêve américain et que rien n'est aussi
beau qu'on qu'on ne le croit c'est pour
ça que j'aime beaucoup le 4 parce que ça
montre un immigré qui vient de
l'exyoslavie qui arrive aux États-Unis
en se disant que ça va être facile en
fait non et il va grimper les échelons
du crime mais voilà c'est enfin j'adore
j'adore le 4 je le préfère largement au
5 désolé oui souvent le débat alors ça
c'est normal c'est c'est un débat tion
d'ailleurs de de on en parlera peut-être
un peu plus tard de ça GTA 6 a l'air
plutôt de reprendre le côté GTA 5 que le
côté GTA 4 qui est plus froid plus oui
bah j'étais à 4 on était pas là pour
rigoler hein ça c'était ce qu'on pouvait
lui reprocher c'est que c'était quand
même assez sombre là on va peut-être
retrouver un peu la folie bon il y avait
viity qui était assez fou moi j'avais
adoré aussi c'était Goni la balade de
Goni qui avait un côté vraiment
flamboyant et très très très très drôle
et je pense que là bon vu le terrain
Miami a quand même moyen de faire des
choses assez sympas effectiv alors dans
les commentaires vous êtes nombreux à
nous en parler P qui le niveau de hype
est maximal je cherche une bonne raison
d'acheter une console et oui parce que
ah bah voilà vous l'avez là vous l'avez
Mo qui nous dit stunt alors de faire des
figures sur le pont effectivement le
pont est cassé ça ça ressemble à un
endroit pour faire voilà parce qu'il y a
toujours plein plein de choses à faire
GTA on disait forcément et donc ça aussi
je voulais en parler parce que on
parlait des réseaux
sociaux GTA est sorti y a 10 ans depuis
10 ans il y a quelque chose qui est
apparu dans nos vies c'est TikTok c'est
ah mais c'est et là dans cette
bandeannonce on en voit énormément
beauoup on voit beaucoup beaucoup de
pastiges de TikTok donc ça je pense
aussi ils vont s'en donner à cœur joie
avec voilà vous voyez des courses de
voiture comme d'habit voà les live avec
les petit cœur et tout non mais là là
ils vont se faire plaisir ils vont
dénoncer à fond je pense que tout ce qui
est le système des influenceurs et tout
ça effectivement ils vont y aller à fond
ils vont bien se moquer euh on a sissan
qui nous salue depuis l'Argentine et qui
va commencer à mettre des sous de côté
oui oui vous avez alors vous avez un peu
le temps pour économiser bah c'est ça
alors ça c'est bien donc tous ceux qui
nous disent enfin qui nous disent ils
souhaitent se dire bon ça va être le
moment d'acheter une console c'est que
vous avez le temps parce que donc la
date de sortie enfin pour le moment
c'est juste 2025 oui donc est-ce qu'on
peut est-ce qu'on peut les croire sur
2025 parce que on a l'impression que le
chantier est tellement titanesque bah
après ça fait longtemps qu'il bosse
dessus hein donc ça fait depuis la
sortie de GTA 5ou B ils ont pas tout de
suite mais bon c'est quand même moins 5
ou 6 ans qui bosse sur GTA 6 et après
bon 2025 ça peut être aussi aussi bien
janvier que décembre donc il y a quand
même un différentiel de de 12 mois entre
les deux donc au mieux c'est dans une
grosse année au pire c'est dans 2 ans
donc donc voilà donc vous pouvez déjà
mettre un peu de des sous de côté tous
les mois dans la tierlire euh avec la
question par contre qui va se poser
c'est sur quelle console elle va sortir
est-ce que c'est que d'abord sur
Playstation estce est-ce qu'il y aura
une sortie PC en même temps alors PC ça
j'en suis pas sûr par contre oui console
ça sortira Xbox et ps5 en même tempsv
forcément ça va sortir sur toutes les
consoles en même temps et ça c'est et ça
c'est et ça c'est sûr euh alors on va
continuer à regarder ce ce trailer donc
avec ces images vous l'avez vu de de de
réseaux sociaux beaucoup beaucoup
d'images de réseaux sociaux euh des des
des clans aussi dans dans la boue donc
dans la campagne a priori euh de de de
Vice City alors là il y avait aussi une
image alors que là jusque là on on a
l'impression que la bandance se fait en
plusieurs plusieurs phases la première
phase c'est on a on a on a fait on a
parlé de l'endroit on a posé les lieux
ensuite on va parler un peu de des
réseaux sociaux on aession énormément
gros passages TikTok place de la vidéo
euh ouis les factions aussi on comprend
fa les gangs les différents gangs et
puis euh donc mais ça voilà on reste sur
la recette la recette classique
différents gangs qui vont s'affronter
euh et non puis là ouais le côté réseaux
sociaux là je voyais que j'avais pas le
temps de le lire tout à l'heure donc
c'est les voisins vigilants aussi enfin
voilà donc on sent que il va et puis les
crocodiles aussi on n pas parlé des
crocodiles on a parlé un peu beaucoup de
crocod d'A juste avant il semblerait que
sur le sur l'image d'avant alors sur
cette image ici ce soit
un c'était c'était un tweet de la ça
apparemment Poch c'est la c'est la c'est
la PA c'est c'est la protection des
animaux de GTA qui est mise qui est mise
en
avant en tout cas comme cela alors
ensuite on va alors déjà pe on parle un
peu aussi des
antidépresseurs aux États-Unis avec
cette pub qui est ici cur emotion on le
sait aussi Rockstar qui se moque pas mal
de de ça et là on rencontre on rencontre
on rencontre notre duo de héros notre
duo alors luuchia c'est sûr et a priori
Jason selon les informations donc c'est
ce duo voilà bah c'est bah là on le voit
c'est le couple et toute façon tout le
reste de du trailer on va les voir tous
les deux en action euh on va les voir
notamment faire un braquage voilà
braquage donc on imagine ça ça va être
les débuts parce que dans GTA on
commence petit dans l'échelle de la
criminalité puis après on va quand même
enfin ça va être très très vite monter
on va arriver à faire des braquages mais
hyper
spectaculaires donc là juste la braquer
la superide du coin on sent que ça va
être c'est juste le démarrage du jeu
avec avec les les deux protagonistes qui
qui qui qui qui démarrent en trom on a
une cinématique aussi où ils se disent
qu' qu'ils vont se faire confiance
jusqu'au bout voilà c'est la fin et
ensuite c'est la fin de ce tra l'URE GTA
6 avec on le disait coming 2025 donc
plus alors on n pas de date forcément
mais est-ce que ça peut être plutôt
début d'année ou plutôt fin d'année ah
bah alors ça j'en sais rien non mais ça
c'est comp enfin c'est compliqué c'est
compliqué de savoir exactement où ça va
où ça va tomber où voilà la flèche va
tomber dans les dans les différents mois
de 2025 et puis sachant
que il y a une tendance dans le jeu
vidéo depuis ces dernières années
notamment avec le V bon là on va on va
en être sorti mais il y a énormément
pardon de décalage de sorti euh donc
beaucoup de jeux qui étaient annoncés
pour fin deannée bon finalement qui
sortent au printemps de l'année
prochaine pour des raisons diverses mais
notamment que les jeux juste sont pas
sont pas terminés donc là on verra et
c'est pour ça que maintenant on voit de
plus en plus de bandannonce où ils
prennent pas de risque
euh il donnent des dates ou des mois où
c'était genre automne fin d'année
premier semestre premier voilà c'était
automne fin d'année printemps maintenant
on donne juste l'année comme ça on prend
le risque est quand même très limité on
dit dit ah ah voilà 2025 ça peut être
1er janvier ça peut être 31 décembre
donc donc ça s'affinera au fur et à
mesure don ne soyons pas trop gourmands
et puis c'est un trailer c'est marqué
trailer numéro 1 donc vous pensez bien
qu'on aura plein d'autres dans les mois
à venir ils vont distyler le le plaisir
au fur à mesure de ces 1 an au mieux 2
ans au pire donc on en saura on en saura
au fur à mesure en fait Rockstar c'est
une boîte qui maîtrise extrêmement bien
sa communication sauf quand il y a des
lics du coup mais sauf quand il y a des
lics mais en temps normal ils savent
très bien maîtriser euh il savent
vraiment faire ça au comp de goutte ils
savent faire monter la sauce enfin là
quand même on sort d'une séquence qui
quand même quand on y réfléchit un peu
absurde de dire il faut une
communication pour dire on va diffuser
en décembre un trailer ensuite une autre
le trailer le 6 décembre et et là bon
bah ça aurait dû être cet après-midi
donc troisème communication pour dire
maintenant voici le trailer ENF on a
quand même une communication en 3 temps
oui parce qu'on s'imaginait qu'il allait
le montrer il y a une grande
cérémonie qui sont les gameward et on
s'imagine que ce trailer était prévu
pour ce momentl alors j'en suis pas sûr
parce qu'en fait Rockstar ils ont
l'habitude juste de snober le type tous
les grands événements genre à le 3 ils y
vont jamais donc le 3 c'est le grand
salon du jeu vidéo qui malheureusement
n'existe plus désormais euh où c'est
normalement la période où on présente
ses plus beaux trailers et ben eux ils
ont toujours fait à leur sauce hein donc
ils se sont toujours mis à part ils vont
jamais au salon euh ils communiquent de
leur côté en fait ils sont tellement
puissants qu'ils ont pas besoin de tout
ces de tous ces relais là ils ont pas
besoin de participer au Game Awards donc
peut-être qu'ils seront là peut-être
qu'ils vont diffuser un trailer
supplémentire mais j'en suis pas sûr Fox
alert qui nous dit fin d'année 2025 je
pense il ne sortira pas avant 2 ans bien
c'est c'est c'est une possibilité
Charles qui nous qui nous remercie de
voir c'est bien deavir des jouralistes
qui connaissent leur sujet ben forcément
on connaî les sujets et on arrive à à
parler aussi de jeux vidéos sur le
Figaro vous pouvez vous abonner sur la
chaîne Youtube on parle jeux vidéo aussi
euh on on peut aussi rappeler parce que
il y a il y a quand même un chiffre ça
fait depuis ce matin que ce que ce que
ce trailer est sorti plus de 55 millions
de vues actuellement ça dit aussi tout
Le phénomène que GTA ah ouais non mais
c'est enfin c'est à mon avis c'est même
je pense que si on prend tous les relais
enfin tous les gens qui aussi diffuser
de leur côté le trailer on doit on doit
atteindre des chiffres phamineux mais
c'est pas surprenant parce qu'en fait
GTA notamment GTA 5 c'est un phénomène
alors j'ai quelques chiffres car je
viens du Figaro économie euh donc GTA
GTA 5 c'est 190 millions de vente en 10
an enfin c'est monstrueux donc il faut
vous dire à peu près là dernièrement
tous les trois moi il y a 5 millions de
GTA 5 qui sont vendus il y a beaucoup de
jeux qui aimeraient faire pareil pour un
jeu qui est sorti il y a 10 ans pour un
jeu qui est sorti il y a 10 ans donc il
y a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de monde
qui aimerait vendre 5 millions
d'exemplaires alors 5 million
d'exemplaires par trimestre alors là ce
serait la joie totale et c'est un jeu en
fait bon déjà ça fait 10 ans il a été en
fait adapté à chaque nouvelle génération
de console parce que c'est un jeu qui à
la base était sorti sur PlayStation 3 on
a tendance à l'oublier PlayStation 3
puis PlayStation 5 là l'année dernière
il y a une version PlayStation
Playstation 4 pardon une version
PlayStation 5 qui est sortie l'année
dernière plus des versions PC aussi qui
était attendu depuis très très longtemps
qui a relancé la machine mais aussi il
faut bien comprendre que GTA pourquoi ça
dure aussi longtemps ce succès c'est
grâce à son mode en ligne c'est GTA
online en fait qui nourrit la bête
depuis depuis 10 ans parce que bon le la
campagne principale on peut en faire le
tour en une trentaine d'heurees à peu
près même si on peut voilà jouer de
manière bacassable dedans au bout d'un
moment quand même on s'en lasse euh non
c'est le mode en ligne en fait qui fait
le succès de GTA et c'est vrai que ça ça
passe un peu sous les radars mais c'est
parce que c'est un mode en ligne qui
fonctionne bien qui est très
régulièrement mise à jour avec du
nouveau contenu et et surtout ce qui est
intéressant c'est que les joueurs qui
sont sur GTA online ils sont vraiment à
fond enfin ils sont vraiment dédiés ils
ont il y a des for enfin des groupes qui
sont absolument incroyables qu' font
vraiment dans ce qu'on appelle du
roleplay c'est-à-dire vraiment il
décident d'incarner par exemple s
décident d'incarner une enseignante ou
un pharmacien bon ben ils vont vraiment
jouer à fond le jeu et donc ils vont
respecter les limitations de vitesse ils
vont jouer de manière honnête après si
on décide d'être plutôt on va dire côté
Brigant enfin voilà ils vont adapter
leur manière de de jouer et c'est assez
fascinant comme phénomène on a dans les
commentaires profiture event qui je
pense est très aime beaucoup les les
entreprises françaises qui nous dit par
rapport à Ubisoft je préfère Ubisoft
dans le genre des des chacun chacun ses
goûts chacun ses goût Rockstar sort
forcément alors il y a aussi une
question par rapport à Rockstar c'est
que ils étaient au top avec GTA ils le
sont restés
commercialement il redad Redemption qui
est sorti aussi en 2018 très grand jeu
forcément pas aussi bien vendu mais très
très grand jeu mais il y mais il y a une
question qui se pose aussi c'est sûr
est-ce que Rockstar est toujours
Rockstar est-ce qu'ils arrivent aussi
bien à à
maîtriser leur production on a eu quand
même quelques petits
problèmes le mode online justement de
Red Dead Redemption 2 qui a pas du tout
marché comme celui de de GTA 5 on a eu
les remaster des anciens GTA qui n'a pas
du tout été aussi bon a bah le oui les
remaster des donc c'était les GTA 3 San
Andreas et je sais plus lequel euh qui
on il y a eu un remaster mais en fait
techniquement ils étaient complètement
enfin c'était juste honteux quoi comme
comme qualité de production donc oui en
fait c'est Rockstar ils peuvent faillir
après vois ça sent par un remaster ça
sent vraiment le projet qui a été confié
à une boîte externe et qui et derrière
dessous de côté assez vite assez vite et
qui voilà juste don les process de
qualité n'ont pas été suiv donc ça c'est
une faute de la part de de l'éditeur euh
après bon bah les mod online tout façon
sur Red Dead ils ont jamais vraiment
fonctionn euh mais après voilà en fait
on attend plus Rockstar sur un peu sa sa
ses QV haut de gamme donc qui sont qui
sont les nouveaux les nouveaux GTA donc
c'est pour ça qu'il vont être attendus
au tournant parce que si GTA 6 est
décevant ça va être dur pour eux euh par
contre si ça tient ses promesses on est
reparti pour un cycle de 10 ans parce
que là GTA à 5 c'est 8 milliards de
dollars de chiffrre d'affaires donc ça
ça fait bien vivre son éditeur teekou on
imagine merci en tout cas que d'avoir
été avec nous merci à vous du Figaro
d'avoir été nombreux à nous suivre euh
on va je vais vous laisser maintenant
merci d'avoir été nombreux en plus dans
les commentaires à nous poser vos
questions j'espère qu'on a répondu à
toutes vos questions et je vous souhaite
une très bonne journée sur le site du
Figaro